JOURNEY.
AISHAH: ALEXIS MCADAMS LIFE
FIRST ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
GRIFF: FOR MORE ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER JOINING IS NOW LIVE TO
WEIGH-IN ARIZONA ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME.
AS YOU SAW IN ALEXIS' REPORT,
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT GETTING
BETTER, IT IS GETTING WORSE.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED 2 MILLION
PLUS.
WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING THE
MIGRANT DEATHS EVEN THOUGH THEY
WILL NOT PUBLISH IT 787 THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
NEVER SEEN THOSE KIND OF NUMBERS
PER 35 ALONE IN SEPTEMBER.
BUT WHAT WE PLAY FOR YOU, IT IS
AT THE POINT NOW FOR OTHER
CHANNELS ARE BEGINNING TO TAKE
NOTICE.
TO REPORT ON IT AND ASK
OFFICIALS WHO, BY THE WEIGHT
REFUSE OUR OPPORTUNITIES TO COME
ON HERE.
BUT SECRETARY WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS CRISIS ON ANOTHER CHANNEL.
HERE WAS THE EXCHANGE I WANT TO
GET YOUR REACTION.
>> SECRETARY I'M HERE IN EL PASO
ABOUT 2000 PEOPLE ARE ARRIVING
EVERY DAY.
LOOK AT ROUGHLY MILLI-
APPREHENSIONS, COUNTLESS OTHERS
ARE CROSSING AND NOT BEING
APPREHENDED.
SECRETARY, WHAT IS THE UNITED
STATES BORDER POLICY?
>> WELL, WE ARE DOING SO MUCH,
JOSÉ PART YOU KNOW WHAT OUR
POLICY IS, IT IS TO ENFORCE THE
LAW.
AND THAT IS INDEED WHAT WE ARE
DOING FOR.
>> MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, ARE
THEY ENFORCING THE LAW?
>> I ACTUALLY THINK THAT ANSWERS
COMICAL.
BUT THIS IS NO JOKE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE PAYING
THE PRICE FOR THIS.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU JUST WENT THROUGH THE RECORD
AMOUNT OF NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS.
JUST IN AUGUST, JUST IN THE
MONTH OF AUGUST MORE PEOPLE HAD
ENCOUNTERS WITH BORDER PATROL
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY THEN THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF LITTLE ROCK,
ARKANSAS.
WE KNOW THAT SINCE BIDEN HAS
TAKEN OVER AS PRESIDENT ENOUGH
TO FILL THREE U.S. STATES OF
CROSS OUR BORDER ILLEGALLY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW PEOPLE ON THE
TERROR WATCH LIST OF COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY AND RECORD AMOUNTS.
WE KNOW FENTANYL IS POURING INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND RECORD AMOUNTS.
AMERICANS ARE DYING.
IN FACT AS A PROSECUTOR RECEIVED
THE PRICE OF FUNCTIONAL FALL
FROM $20 A PILL TO $5 A PILL, I
KNOW OUR SONS, DAUGHTERS,
NIECES, NEPHEWS, OUR CHILDREN
ARE GOING TO BE DYING.
THAT IS LACEY STAGGERING NUMBERS
WERE MOST PEOPLE KNOW IN THE
GROUP OF 18 -- 49 ARE DYING AS A
RESULT OF THOSE OVERDOSES.
SO AMERICANS ARE DYING, PEOPLE
ARE COMING IN RECORD NUMBERS BUT
CRIMINALS ARE COMING IN,
AMERICA'S LESS SAFE.
BUT I DO NOT KNOW WHAT MEASURES
SECRETARY MAYORKAS IS USING.
I THINK THEIR LACK OF INTEGRITY
IS ONLY SURPASSED BY HIS
INEPTITUDE.
GRIFF: ARE ARIZONANS PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS?
IS THIS GOING TO BE AN ISSUE FOR
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS THEY ARE
IN YOUR STATE?
>> YES.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE DEATHLY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
I HAVE SAID THIS FOR THE LAST
YEAR, THIS ELECTION IS AND
SHOULD BE ABOUT SECURITY.
BORDER SECURITY, ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
PEOPLE WANT TO FEEL SAFE.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO SEND
THEIR KIDS ARE GOOD SCHOOL AND
NOT KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
INUNDATED WITH DRUGS OR THE KIDS
ARE WALKING TO SCHOOL THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GUNNED DOWN AS A
RESULT OF GANG VIOLENCE AS THE
CARTELS PERPETUATE MORE AND MORE
VIOLENCE INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO IT SHOULDN'T MATTER.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY I ALSO
THINK THE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR ECONOMY BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN'S AMERICA, GAS PRICES ARE
RISING RECORD NUMBERS GRID
GROCERY PRICES ARE RISING.
WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY
THING JOE BIDEN THINGS IS WRONG
WITH OUR BORDER IS THAT HE
CANNOT LET MORE ILLEGAL PEOPLE
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
GRIFF: WILL SEE HOW ARIZONANS
REACT TO THE BORDER ISSUE.
I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT THOUGH
AND SHIFTED GEARS MR. ATTORNEY
GENERAL IF I CAN JUST TO THE
NEWS COMING LATE YESTERDAY, A
RULING WITH REGARDS TO ABORTION,
UNDOING DECADES OLD LAW THAT
WOULD BAN OUTRIGHT ABORTIONS.
IT COMES ON THE SAME DAY, TODAY
WHEN THE 15 WEEK LAW WAS SET TO
TAKE EFFECT.
AND SO IF YOU COULD, SIR, JUST
CLARIFY FOR ALL ARIZONANS,
EXACTLY WHAT THE LAW IS TODAY AS
WE SPEAK AND WHERE THINGS STAND.
>> WE WERE INVOLVED IN
LITIGATION TRYING TO CLARIFY THE
LAW.
AND YESTERDAY A JUDGE SAID ARS
13 -- SIX OH THREE, RICOTTA
FIGHT IN 1977 WHICH WAS BASED ON
A PREVIOUS LAW THAT BASICALLY
SAID ALL ABORTIONS ARE ILLEGAL
IN ARIZONA EXCEPT IN THE CASE TO
SAVE THE MOTHER.
ME PERSONALLY I'VE SAID BEFORE I
THINK THERE SHOULD BE EXCEPTIONS
FOR RAPE AND INCEST.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE LAW IS.
JUST THIS YEAR OUR LEGISLATURE
THAT RICOTTA FIGHT OR PAST THE
BAY ON A 15 WEEK BAND THEY
LITERALLY SAID IN THEIR AND
13 -- 3603 IS NOT REPEALED, IS
STILL THE LAW IN ARIZONA.
SO WE HAVE A LAW FROM 1977, HAVE
A LAW PASSED THIS YEAR THAT BOTH
SAY THERE IS A COMPLETE BAN.
THAT IS WHAT THE JUDGE SAID IS
INDEED THE VALID LAW IN ARIZONA.
GRIFF: OF THE TOTAL BAN, EXCEPT
FOR WHEN IT THREATENS THE
PREGNANT MOTHER'S LIFE IS IN
EFFECT TODAY AND FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE FOR ALL WOMEN
IN ARIZONA.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO WOMEN
WHO ARE SAYING THEY NOW WILL
HAVE TO TRAVEL TO OTHER STATES
AND THAT THEY FEEL THEIR RIGHTS
HAVE BEEN SET BACK FOR DECADES.
>> THE JOB OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS TO ENFORCE THE LAW AS
IT IS.
I HAVE SAID THIS MANY A TIME ON
VARIOUS ISSUES INCLUDING THIS
ISSUE OF ABORTION WHICH IS IN
MANY WAYS SO EMOTIONAL AND
CONTROVERSY OVER PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS OUT THERE
SAYING THEY WANT TO PROTECT LIFE
AND PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING WHAT
WOMEN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
BUT ULTIMATELY YOU HAVE A
REPUBLICAN LEGISLATURE AND YOU
HAVE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR THAT
SIGNED A BILL THAT SAID THIS IS
THE LAW IN ARIZONA.
SO PEOPLE DO NOT LIKE THE LAW
THEY SHOULD TAKE IT UP WITH
THEIR LEGISLATORS OR THEY SHOULD
TAKE IT UP WITH THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN CONGRESS.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL, MARK THANKS
SO MUCH FOR COMING